I'm gonna need everything all the info
you got you'll get it when the team gets
it no team this is gonna have to be me
alone
it's not that simple the crew were after
they hit like thunder and disappear like
smoke you going alone you won't ever
touch him when chasing this guy across
four continents in 12 countries and
believe me the last damn place I want to
be right now is on your front doorstep
selling girl scout cookies I need your
help Dom I need your team
ladies dead on I need to know for sure
but I'm going with you you said you were
gonna leave this life behind he both
said that we were leaving the life
behind he's right
we're family we got a problem we deal
with it together
Oh
yeah
if that's the way it has to go oh let me
guess palms come on you sumbitch
Oh
you
yeah very interested to find the man who
bought those why should I help you
because we're asking you nice because
you're asking me nicely so what can you
offer like I get from the thousand other
girls hmm you look like a man who likes
it rough
got some serious balls now I've been
told no you're lucky I miss my shot I
think you hit your mark really what is
it with you what do you got a death wish
or something that's what it takes I just
want to race yeah it's not dummy-proof
man I've been known to handle big guns
relax you've been known to handle that
big-ass hey hey Dom I did some check-in
passed around got the location of a
street race tonight
just like old times
freeze with mad
you